Mời công bố của biển sá hội học của tế ký, khoảng 15% lưu khuên nè đã phản đối về chim nhận kế hoạch qua mình.
Bà gồm được dú quân khỏi đôn bác, và chỉ quân số mặt thung có bảo đảm anh ninh.
Hảo xan được thực hiện từ ngày 20, sau thông quý một đến ngày 20, năm 2020, trên toàn lãnh tổ quen nè,
phản nãnh sáu quán điểm dộng sái của người dân về và đi ngày.
Phà lớn nơi được hỏi uống hộng sải pháp đong mắc xung đồn.
Muy được kiện lúc quen nè không bị ae công nhận các khu vực rất lực lượng ngay kìm sát,
trong trong tiền tưởng xung đồ của thịt kế thông vào đau hoặc dưới năm 2020.
Cung ngay và biểu xung của gặp với các của văn an ninh của những cuu gia đu tá,
tổng thống uống khuy nè với lo đia trên lãnh sĩ cho biết,
có thể chính sử vấn tiếp diễn và một số yêu cầu sẽ này sình.
Điều đó, không có nghĩa là uống khuy nè phải đáp ứng cơ yêu cầu của ngà,
và uống khuy nè sẽ tìm kiểm thoại vừa hợp để vẫn cứ đưa xung hộ của Mỹ trong tiền trình đảm phán.
Về tình yên chính sử, đưa bác sĩ tục là điểm ngắm khi ngà hiện gần như kiểm soát bộ lu hãn,
trong khi ở đu nhiên s, ngà chiếm hộ bởi vì phần chăm con uống khuy nè dùi chỉ bác phần chăm lạnh thuộc còn lại.